aquí dibujé la gráfica de una función
media lo que hace esto hace como una n
luego una u tiene un pico y baja lo que
quiero hacer ahorita es platicar acerca
de sus máximos y de sus mínimos pero
antes déjame decirte que esta función
así en este ejemplo después del
intervalo o sea hacia la izquierda sigue
bajando hacia infinito o sea aquí sigue
bajando lo voy a poner así punteado para
indicar que sigue bajando y de este lado
también va entonces baja y baja y baja y
tiene valores cada vez más y más
negativos así hasta menos infinito
entonces vamos a empezar a analizar
algunos mix mínimos y máximos de esta
función por ejemplo acá arriba acá
arriba tenemos un valor vamos a llamarle
a este punto en el eje x vamos a
llamarle x0 y a esta altura vamos a
ponerle f x él
y lo que le sucede a este valor es que
es un máximo global déjame poner algunas
líneas punteadas para que quede un poco
más bonito o algo así estoy acá es un
máximo global porque es un máximo global
máximo global global pues justo porque
efe de x0 le gana a efe x para cualquier
otro valor de x que tomemos entonces efe
x 0 es lo más que podemos alcanzar para
toda esta función vale eso quiere decir
que es un máximo global ahora mi
pregunta sería existe algún mínimo
mínimo global mínimo global
global pues no no hay un mínimo global
para esta función para efe porque pues
por más que intentemos obtener el valor
más chico como la función baja a menos
infinito tanto de este lado como de este
lado pues vamos a tener valores más y
más chicos entonces no vamos a poder
encontrar un mínimo global bueno pero
estos son cosas globales o sea que
funcionan para todos los valores de x
sin embargo también hay mínimos y
máximos locales es decir mínimos y
máximos que son mínimos y máximos navas
en un cachito en un intervalo a lo mejor
ahorita no voy a hacer muy estricto con
la definición pero bueno vamos a ver por
ejemplo donde vemos que hay como un
mínimo local más o menos por acá porque
pues mira aquí tenemos un punto vamos a
llamarle x 1 x 1 y a la altura
correspondiente pues efe x 1 y aunque no
es el más chiquito de todos podemos
agarrarnos un intervalo alrededor de
modo que si sea el más chiquito en ese
intervalo va otra vez esto no es la
definición así completamente formal pero
podemos pensar la de esa forma va
entonces este de aquí sería un mínimo
local
qué sucede con este punto de acá con
este punto que voy a pintar en color
naranja si le llamamos x2 de manera
similar ahora es un máximo local porque
alcanza el mayor valor para los puntos
que están cerquita de él sí o sea al
acercarnos lo suficiente es un punto
donde se alcanza un valor máximo ok
entonces fíjate ya tenemos un máximo
global déjame escribirle que por acá
tenemos un mínimo local mínimo mínimo
local local
efe x1 y finalmente que acá tenemos un
máximo local
máximo máximo local no vocal
efe de x2 muy bien ya tenemos esos tres
valores y lo que quiero hacer ahorita es
que nos preguntemos cómo está
relacionado ser un máximo y un mínimo
con la derivada entonces vamos a pensar
en esto déjame tomar un color
central para hacer la derivada entonces
qué sucede aquí alrededor del máximo
global pues a la izquierda del máximo
global tenemos una derivada que es
positiva verdad es o sea la función es
creciente la derivada es positiva luego
tenemos una derivada que es menos
positiva menos positiva y justo en este
punto la derivada se hace cero qué pasa
si seguimos avanzando pues ahora va a
ser negativa la derivada más su más
negativa de máxima negativa pero lo
importante es que aquí
efe lima/efe prima de x0 fue igual a
cero bueno vámonos al mínimo local de
manera similar al acercarnos a este
mínimo tenemos que la derivada se va
haciendo cada vez más y más horizontal
sí bueno la línea tangente se va
haciendo más horizontal y por tanto la
derivada se va acercando a cero entonces
justo en este punto en x1 también
tenemos que f prima de x 1 es igual a 0
eso está ya como que medio sospechoso
verdad vamos al tercer punto a ver qué
pasa pues aquí tenemos que la derivada
es positiva
más o menos bueno es muy positiva pero
luego así repentinamente de manera
abrupta se hace negativa entonces aquí
en el mero x2 aquí en este puntito la
derivada no está definida va entonces
aquí le voy a poner que ese primer x 2
no está no está definida de fin
a este es un fenómeno muy interesante
verdad vamos a apuntarlo por acá abajo
vamos a ver qué le sucede a los máximos
y los mínimos entonces si tenemos un
mínimo un mínimo y un máximo máximo sale
que no sea el extremo de un intervalo no
extremo un extremo de intervalo de
intervalo
entonces bueno o sea mínimo máximo no
extremo de intervalo en el punto x
igualada necesitamos poner esto entonces
tenemos que o bien f prima de a es igual
a cero o bien
efe primera a no está definida no está
definida de vida ahora déjame aclarar un
poco esto de que no sea el extremo de un
intervalo porque no te platicaba cabeza
entonces mira o sea lo que puede pasar y
qué es el caso que no nos interesa
ahorita lo que puede pasar es que ahí
tengamos los ejes y aquí una función
pero que esta función está definida nada
más en un cachito sí o sea nada más en
un intervalo digamos en este intervalo
de acá entonces a lo que me refiero con
que se alcance un mínimo o máximo que no
sea en el extremo de un intervalo es que
no nos importan y este punto ni este
punto va entonces hay funciones que sólo
están definidas digamos de 1 a 4 y
ahorita no nos importa fijarnos en el
uno ni en el 4 si no nada más en los
puntos interiores entonces tenemos este
resultado de acá si tenemos un mínimo o
un máximo que no esté en el extremo de
un intervalo para eso es importante y
ese mínimo máximo es en el punto x es
igual a entonces tenemos esta igualdad
de acá déjame ponerlo en un cuadrito
para qué
para que la tengamos muy en cuenta
ok bueno entonces esto cumple estoy acá
y estos puntos donde la deriva de 0 o no
está definida tienen un nombre especial
se les conoce como puntos críticos
puntos críticos críticos de la función
en este caso sería de de f entonces
déjame escribir por acá quienes serían
los puntos críticos
voy a poner puntos críticos críticos
tenemos los puntos críticos de efe
serían x0
aquí tenemos x 0 sería x1
y x1 y finalmente tenemos x 2 x 2 ahora
mi pregunta es la siguiente estos son
los únicos puntos críticos no verdad al
parecer hay otro y eso está muy
relacionado con lo siguiente o sea un
mínimo o máximo implica que la derivada
de 0 o no está definida qué tal al revés
será cierto que todos los puntos
críticos nos dan mínimos o máximos de la
función los puntos críticos nos darán
los valores extremos de la función bueno
pues vamos a ver a ver si esta función
tiene otro punto crítico aquí viene la
derivada es positiva 0 negativa negativa
0 positiva no está definida negativa y
aquí se vuelve a hacer 0 verdad entonces
déjame marcar este punto que parece ser
interesante más o menos por acá vamos a
llamarle x 3 en este punto también
tenemos también tenemos que f prima de x
3 es igual a 0 entonces la derivada en x
3 también es 0 x 3 es un punto crítico
sin embargo hay que tener cuidado porque
x 3 no es ni un mínimo local ni un
máximo local
ni nada por más que nos acerquemos hay
puntitos por arriba y hay puntitos por
abajo ok entonces eso está súper bueno
verdad ya tenemos no sólo que que los
mínimos o máximos éste nos dan o sea que
son puntos críticos sino que no
necesariamente los puntos críticos son
mínimos o máximos del intervalo entonces
es como un semi criterio bueno entonces
ahí está ya tenemos oa cuáles son los
puntos críticos una buena pregunta que
vamos a explorar en el siguiente vídeo
es cómo le hacemos para saber ya que
tenemos los puntos críticos si esos son
mínimos o si son máximos o si no son
ninguna de las dos
bueno nos vemos en el próximo vídeo